hello and welcome to this episode of the
apigee accelerator Series in this video
we'll be demonstrating how to create and
send custom log messages from an apigee
API proxy to Google Cloud login
in this example our sample proxy will be
sending regular API traffic to the back
end one important aspect is that I'll be
using apigee's Google authentication
feature that allows a given API proxy to
easily authenticate to any Google cloud
service using the credentials of a
service account let's get started in
order to run the sample you need the
following
prerequisites an active appigax instance
configured for receiving external
traffic the following tools in your
terminal and also permissions for
creating service accounts set in its IEM
permissions and creating and deploying
API proxies for this video we'll be
using the cloud shell tutorial so we can
quickly get started and all the tools
are already pre-configured
okay now that we are in the Google Cloud
shell environment you can follow along
with the step-by-step instructions on
the right hand side
first let's make sure we're logged in
with the correct account
all right so allow test CG into the
cloud login directory
and next step is customizing the env.sh
file with the required information we
can click here
and add our information such as our RPG
project the host Alias the environment
that we need for executing the sample
remember to save
your file let's Source it
and then we can get started
next step is just executing the deploy
script
display script will deploy the API proxy
the service account set its permissions
and then we can see how it works it can
take a few moments
all right now that the script is finally
over let's take the next steps first
let's generate a few sample API calls
and next let's try to read the log
messages that this calls generated from
Google Cloud logging using the gcloud
CLI tool
let's read it again
there you go now let's see more details
what's configured in apigee
foreign
proxy we just created
the first thing to notice is that this
API proxy is deployed to have the
permissions of a service account that
the script also created so you can see
it here
now click the develop tab
and let's see what this proxy is all
about
if you see over here it has just a
single message logging policy executing
the post client flow this is a special
flow that is executed after the response
is sent to the client it's very useful
to not add any latency in issuing this
log message let's see the policy itself
in the policy see that we set the log
name we want to use
some system variables here organization
environment some information about the
request itself the response code content
and even a liter of value
to finalize let's just double check the
service account that we
the script created let me just refresh
so here it is with the logs writer
permission and last but not least let's
check our log messages in the UI
of cloud login of course
so here we can see in more details the
log messages we sent
to finalize black back to cloud cloud
shell
please hate this tutorial
and if you want to clean up just execute
the cleanup script
thank you
we hope you found this sample useful and
if you enjoyed the video please hit the
like button below you can subscribe to
our channel to see more videos in the
series if you have any questions please
post them in the apigee community thank
you so much for watching